Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Vous connaissez sans doute cet immense tube d'Orelsan.
"La terre est ronde"
Eh bien, elle n'a pas tort.
On sait depuis l'Antiquité que notre planète est de forme
plus ou moins sphérique.
Et pourtant, certains en doutent.
Allez, je vous apporte quelques preuves que la Terre est bien ronde.
Des preuves qui reposent sur des observations que vous pouvez faire vous même.
Allez, ça tourne.
Au fond, je sais que la terre est ronde...
D'abord, un peu d'Histoire.
L'idée que la Terre est ronde n'est pas nouvelle.
Le mathématicien grec Pythagore, celui du théorème, le supposait déjà
5 siècles avant Jésus-Christ,
sans toutefois être en mesure de
le prouver.
Deux autres grecs, Aristote puis Ératosthène, parviendront finalement
à le démontrer plus de 3 siècles avant notre ère.
Pour le prouver,
ce dernier, Ératosthène,
a eu l'idée de planter deux bâtons
à des endroits très éloignés, l'un plus au nord que l'autre.
Puis il a mesuré leur ombre projetée à la même heure.
Si la Terre avait été plate,
ces ombres auraient été strictement identiques.
Or, ce n'est pas le cas.
Celle plus au nord était plus longue.
Ce phénomène ne peut s'expliquer que par la rotondité de la Terre.
Et pourtant,
aujourd'hui encore,
certains sont persuadés que la Terre est plate et qu'on leur ment.
Tenez, en 2020, un certain Mike Hughes
a perdu la vie en voulant en apporter la preuve.
Il a péri aux commandes d'une fusée
qu'il avait construite dans son garage.
Il voulait prendre des photos de la Terre à 1500 mètres d'altitude,
pour démontrer qu'elle était parfaitement plate.
Heureusement,
la plupart des platistes, c'est le nom qu'on leur donne, sont plus terre à terre.
Certains avancent que si la Terre était ronde,
les habitants de l'hémisphère sud auraient la tête en bas
et tomberaient dans le vide.
Franchement, ça ne tient pas debout.
En effet, quel que soit le lieu où l'on se trouve sur Terre,
nos deux pieds sont parfaitement collés au plancher des vaches.
Ceci grâce à une force fondamentale :
La gravité.
Cette force attire tous les objets vers le centre de la Terre.
Nous y compris.
Si la terre était plate,
la gravité ne produirait pas du tout les mêmes effets sur les objets.
Allez, on va faire un peu de science fiction.
Imaginons que notre planète se présente sous la forme d'un disque
comme ce vieux 33 tours,
au dessus duquel
je vais placer un fil à plomb.
Si la Terre était plate, le centre de gravité se trouverait
au centre du disque, ici,
et le plomb serait attiré dans cette direction.
Sauf qu'en fonction de l'endroit où on se trouve sur le disque,
le fil serait plus ou moins incliné,
à l'exception, bien sûr
à l'aplomb du centre du disque.
Imaginez ce que ça donnerait pour nous les humains.
On vivrait penché, et de plus en plus
au fur et à mesure que l'on s'éloignerait du centre.
Le même phénomène se produirait avec les arbres, les monuments.
Ce n'est évidemment pas le cas.
Comme la terre est une sphère,
nous sommes toujours à la même distance de son centre
et la force de gravité
s'exerce toujours de la même manière, perpendiculaire au sol.
C'est ce qui nous permet de tenir debout et qui fait
qu'un objet tombe toujours à la verticale,
comme notre fameux fil à plomb.
C'est le physicien
Isaac Newton qui a mis ce phénomène en évidence au XVIIᵉ siècle.
La légende veut qu'il ait eu la révélation en observant
une pomme tombée d'un arbre.
Elle est bien ronde celle-ci aussi.
La deuxième observation simple
qui prouve la rotondité de la Terre est bien plus ancienne.
On la doit au philosophe grec Aristote qui a été le premier
à la réaliser 3 siècles et demi avant Jésus-Christ.
Pour y parvenir, il a observé le ciel à l'occasion d'une éclipse de Lune
Ce phénomène se produit lorsque la Terre vient se placer
pile poil entre le Soleil et la Lune.
Et que remarque Aristote ?
Eh bien, il constate que l'ombre de la Terre recouvre progressivement
la surface lunaire et surtout que cette ombre est arrondie.
Cet arc de cercle, selon lui, est bien
la preuve que la Terre a une forme sphérique et non pas plate.
Si la Terre était plate, voilà ce que ça donnerait.
Or, personne n'a jamais vu ça.
Une autre observation, facile à réaliser
lorsque vous vous promenez en bord de mer et que vous regardez les bateaux s'éloigner de la côte.
Plus un navire file vers le large plus sa taille diminue
jusqu'au moment où il finit par disparaître complètement.
Ce n'est pas une question d'acuité visuelle.
Même avec la lunette la plus puissante du monde,
il y a un moment où le bateau finit par disparaître.
À cause de la courbure de la Terre
au niveau de la mer, l'horizon se trouve à environ 5 kilomètres.
Pour un homme de taille moyenne.
La courbure de notre planète nous empêche de voir au delà.
Tenez.
La prochaine fois que vous vous baladez en bord de mer, observez ce qui se passe au moment où le bateau
franchit la ligne d'horizon.
C'est toujours l'avant du navire
qui disparaît en premier, comme si celui-ci plongeait vers l'avant.
Si la Terre était plate, avec une longue vue
on pourrait le suivre infiniment plus longtemps
Je vais utiliser cette lampe pour symboliser le Soleil.
Si la Terre était plate
comme ce planisphère, toute la planète serait éclairée en même temps.
Alors certes, le Soleil serait plus ou moins haut
en fonction de l'endroit où on se trouve.
Mais dès l'instant où le soleil franchirait la ligne d'horizon,
il ferait jour partout au même moment.
Jour, nuit, jour, nuit,
jour nuit.
Et si la Terre était plate ?
Le soleil se lèverait à la même heure pour tout le monde
et en toute logique,
il se coucherait aussi à la même heure pour tout le monde.
Or, vous le savez, ce n'est pas ce qui se passe
lorsqu'il est 9 h du matin à Paris, par exemple,
et qu'il fait jour.
À New York, il n'est que 4 h du matin et il fait encore nuit.
Inversement, quelques heures plus tard, alors qu'il est 18 h à New York
et qu'il fait encore jour, il est 23 h à Paris et il fait nuit.
C'est bien la preuve que la Terre tourne sur elle même.
Un tour en 24h.
Et quelle est ronde.
Si vous doutez encore,
je vous invite maintenant à lever les yeux au ciel
quand il fait nuit.
Avec un télescope,
Vous pointez Mars ou Saturne et là, que voyez-vous ?
Deux planètes rondes, comme toutes les planètes connues dans l'univers.
Je sais, certains diront qu'il s'agit de disques et pas de sphères.
En poursuivant l'observation,
vous constatez que des détails défilent à la surface.
Ils apparaissent d'un côté et disparaissent de l'autre.
C'est donc bien la preuve que ces planètes sont sphériques.
Du coup, si nos voisines sont sphériques,
pourquoi la Terre serait-elle plate ?
Allez, on va finir en beauté.
L'ultime preuve de la rotondité de la Terre a été fournie
par la mission Apollo 17 en 1972.
Il s'agit de la toute première photo de la Terre
complète prise depuis l'espace.
Les Américains l'ont surnommé "Blue Marble" :
La bille bleue
Pas de doute, notre terre est bien ronde.
Voilà, j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu, que vous y voyez plus clair,
que vous disposez de tous les arguments
pour défendre la rotondité de la Terre.
Je vous dis à très bientôt.
En attendant, si ce n'est pas déjà fait,
je vous invite à vous abonner à la chaîne Épicurieux,
il n'y a rien de plus encourageant pour nous
que de voir cette belle communauté
d'Épicurieuses et d'Épicurieux s'étoffer.